we got this story from
news uh from sky news omicron variant
highly infectious and booster jabs may
need double dose says moderna ceo it is
a official
big pharma narrative
sky news that you will need to get a
double dose of the booster because of
the new variant so there there's there's
no slowing this there's a slowing the
spread i guess but there's no stopping
it if this is our plan of action and
you've got a mainstream uh narrative
from a lot of these people
just get
it's like you mentioned earlier luke
they say just get the first shot and
we're good everyone will be fine they
said in new york city the mandate was
one shot at least now it's you know
they're saying okay well now you get
then you then it was get two doses for
fully vaccinated then they said you
gotta get your booster now they're
saying no no the third shot is not a
booster it's a normal part of the whole
vaccine process and now imagine this
imagine you got three shots already and
they're saying that's not a booster
the ceo of madonna is now saying you
will need two more shots
because of omicron
it's like a rainmaker selling umbrellas
that's my personal perspective on it but
but again we have to understand who does
this kind of benefit here where's the
accountability where's the oversight
where's people saying hey let's actually
take a look at this and and let's maybe
see if some people are maybe motivated
more by profit than they are about
general health and if we are interested
in general health shouldn't we have
conversations about obesity shouldn't we
have conversations about diet and if you
want to have a totalitarian response to
this shore but if you're going to be
attacking anyone it should be maybe kfc
mcdonald's burger king especially if
you're caring about people's health uh
but but again
it's it's ridiculous to even think about
it that way
and and again people's health is
important and the discussions about
exercise vitamin d getting proper sleep
not being stressed out making sure that
you're living a life that is a healthy
happy one rather than just a wage slave
one where you're indoctrinated by just
horrible ideas and horrible foods that
go into your system and make you a
crappy unhealthy unhappy person you know
we if we want to start those
conversations we should have them and i
think we would have a far better effect
at helping people when it comes to
making people healthier than we would by
just giving all of our full faith to big
pharma because as we know they're
treated like our overlords right now
i'm not surprised that this ceo of a
pharmaceutical company is suggesting
that his vaccine is the is the way to go
forward no no no no
i'm not surprised that he's saying you
actually need two yeah okay i'm a window
maker and have you considered putting
two windows in the same right the people
when there's a health crisis you don't
want to be looking to your
pharmaceutical ceos for the the way
forward necessary we sound like such
leftists
these big corporations are just trying
to turn a profit exploiting the health
crisis and we should
yeah i mean they were true
yeah where where where are the uh this
is the problem i have with like the left
is that when we've heard of the left we
are quite literally referring to leftist
populists and the establishment because
for whatever reason they're aligned on
this one
you take a look at the most prominent
personalities they have and they agree
on all this stuff and i'm like yo how
come you guys are pro-big pharma now
maybe it's because quite simply the new
generation of leftists
they were you know teenagers 10 years
ago so when the occupy wall street types
were out there saying like big pharma is
bad
those people are now in their mid to
late 30s and these 20 something year
olds who are on youtube and pushing this
politics to the far left were born into
a world where big farm is actually good
martin shkreli awesome guy apparently i
guess that's their position okay sure
and and the record of some of these
companies record fines bribing doctors
bribing regulat regulators buying off
corporate media i can name a lot of
individuals i could name a lot of
multinational corporations that of
course were guilty of this but but they
have a criminal past they're liable for
causing real life human harm before
and
for people to just to give them a pass
to a blind trust because you know
there's a tragedy that's being exploited
here is something that is worrying
personally myself that that i am
concerned about uh from my own personal
perspective also the way that they're
funding research too like i was
listening to this one
cardiologist in the uk that majid nawaz
was interviewing by the i don't know if
you've seen his content lately
on twitter he's been great on this and
the cardiologist was saying that 66 of
academic research done
on medical issues is funded by drug
companies so that creates a huge bias so
a number of researchers are unable to
publish certain kind of research that
goes against the efficacy of a certain
drug that can lead to
i think joe was pointing out recently on
his podcast joe rogan and several drugs
dozens of drugs that have been pulled
off the market that were initially
approved and led to so many excess
deaths and injuries and that was because
the studies that were done that showed
the efficacy were tainted by this
influence from the drug industry and it
led to so many deaths
i mean ever you guys have seen the
brought to you by modern montage oh yeah
oh yeah cnn's new day brought to you by
pfizer and that shows like all the media
saying that
yeah man
when you have commercials it's i think
the united states is one of only like
what i think like two countries that
allow commercials for drugs and the best
part about it i love this is that they
don't tell what the drugs do
floor nostrin call your doctor to see if
it's right for you like they won't tell
you what it is
but they want you to buy it yeah they'll
show like an old woman and man dancing
in the field
in slow motion this could be you yeah
just take our drugs restless leg
syndrome we have a solution and then
side effects include
food that our other companies
sells you take our medicine that are
other companies you're feeling stressed
it's take this it's a joke like people
do sketches where it's like side effects
may include you know explosive diarrhea
but like i was actually i saw an ad
recently for some medication where they
actually said i i i verbally exclaimed
in my living room when we were watching
some show
and it was like get this treatment and
the side effects include like bleeding
heart or something or just like some
ridiculous thing where it was like you
know blood clots and you know deep vein
thrombosis and other and like cardiac
arrest and i was like why would you take
that it was like do you have you know
irritable bowel syndrome take this thing
that can stop your heart and it's like
maybe not i don't know maybe you just
gotta go to the bathroom and you know
like because that side effects are crazy
i don't know man but but you know what
you know what far be it from me right if
somebody's got some kind of you know
disease and they're suffering and they
say i'll take the risk if it makes my
life better that's between them their
doctor ultimately they make a choice
about what's right for them not
commercials you're right the united
states and new zealand are the only
countries in the world that allow drug
advertising on commercials right now and
it's pretty much all you see especially
if you watch the corporate media you
just see pharma ad after pharma ad at
the farmer ad now again we also have to
be uh intellectually honest here not all
of big pharma's evil some of the stuff
that they do produce does really help
people has revolutionized medicine and
has changed people's lives for the
better we have to admit that on a
certain level but there is a very
sinister nasty disgusting element of it
that literally profits off of human
suffering rather cures the symptoms than
the cause and is knowingly making money
hiding real cures because of someone
sitting at an office saying i prefer
money over human life we saw that with
the opioid epidemic we saw that with
institutions in this country being
bought out by big pharma that literally
turned a huge portion of this country
into heroin addicts knowingly because of
big money and when you have that much of
power that much influence that much harm
caused by this industry i'm sorry you
you don't have my faith you don't have
my personal belief system in you you
don't i'm not gonna give you the benefit
of the doubt you don't deserve it okay
bernie bro
it's true
and then you got the prison industrial
complex saying these working-class you
know family men who lost their jobs to
the factories being shipped overseas who
then got hooked on opioids should go to
prison for it and the police with smiles
on their faces kick in the doors of the
victims working-class people in this
country and send them to jail yep yeah
the whole system but you know the
problem is yo i can see it right luke
can see it we can all see it big
pharmaceutical companies exploiting a
crisis exploiting pain
pumping opioids into this country the
the policies of the of the democratic
and republican establishment extracting
factories and jobs from this country
overseas to make a quick buck and the
prison industrial complex and we can all
see it and then the only thing we get
is the left saying communism is the
answer
more government more police officers
more money for big pharma more money for
the big prison industry it's more
government intervention in our daily
lives which is insane i do support using
the government's uh power to disrupt the
monopoly of making pharmaceutical
commercials
legal i would like to the government to
make them illegal like they did with
tobacco commercials in the 60s or
whatever was the 70s um that is maybe a
little socialist in me but i think that
there's a time and a place
heavy hammer of the government to
prevent these private companies from
taking over that's that's not socialist
that's that's that's something we can do
reasonably as a people as a community as
a country as a nation and be like here's
what we agree and don't agree on how
these companies should function i think
regulations are fine the problem is when
they never get removed and they're
outdated or broken in some ways so what
ends up happening is clause exactly yeah
we say okay we're going to try this out
we're going to do a two-year you know
ban on pharmaceutical commercials or
something and then we'll see how it
happens and if it's and then in two
years it sunsets and then you know we'll
have to re-vote for it or something like
that and all the politicians that got
bribed for two years by the farmers
industry so that when they vote next
time no it'll naturally sunset
it'll just disappear the law would just
be gone
that that is a big problem you know the
lobbying and all that stuff and and the
promises there's no real way around it
because they'll just be like look we
can't give you anything but when you're
out in two years we'll give you a
high-paying job in in in the company i
just you know
it's not socialist to say
the present industrial complex
well
actually it's it's anti-socialist i
should say
the government subsidizes private
prisons
guaranteeing cust like contracts
so you'll get a dude who is hooked on
opiates because he was prescribed it
they get addicted where they're in
extreme pain they don't get any more the
doctor says no you're cut off and they
become desperate they go through
withdrawals and they could die from this
and so then they they they you know
they seek out non-legal methods for
obtaining this to help themselves then
they go to prison and the government
says we got no issue with that private
prison system here's somebody to throw
into the machine and we will pay you for
it and what's happening is our tax
dollars are paying for a broken machine
that is not helping these people that is
only incentivizing this so i'll tell you
this that's not capitalism
that's that's that's that's more akin to
communism and socialism than capitalism
the problem is first of all most
conservatives don't talk about this they
don't seem to care private prisons is
not a big issue for them trump wasn't
you know interested in prison reform but
when the left brings it up they're like
this is a problem of capitalism and i'm
like what about the government taking
the money from the people by force to
fund these corrupt prison systems is
capitalism and and creating absurd laws
that put innocent people that didn't
harm anyone behind j in jail i mean that
absolutely makes no sense i think
a perfect meme that i saw that
represents the larger ideas that you're
trying to get across here tim was a
protester screaming that we need more
government and then there was a full-on
riot cop with pepper spray pepper
spraying her in the face and then the
pepper spray was more government and she
was getting all of it because again you
look at this kind of reciprocal cycle
they create all these stupid laws that
create victimless crimes that put people
in jail when they shouldn't be there
they come out worse criminals they they
come out destroyed they come out without
having uh you know their rights they
come out without
you know a sense of decency they come
out in a situation where they can't even
probably get a job in most places it's
not always the case but again
they create a situation that
incentivizes some of the worst behavior
in this world and then we're asking
ourselves why do we have one of the
largest prison populations we wonder why
it's it's a big business and people
profit off of it speaking of victimless
crimes brother this morning i was
looking at
certain reports that were released from
austria showing that um starting in
february
people who don't take the vaccine might
be incarcerated yeah those are still
preliminary those are still preliminary
reports but we do know for sure there's
gonna be a four thousand dollar fine
starting in february for those people
who don't get vaccinated this is
mainstream news not conspiracy at all
it's incredible it's incredible that
they can exercise that much control like
across europe you're seeing that like in
slovenia the small european country they
dabbled with the policy that um people
who were filling up on on gas had to
show their covet certificate otherwise
they couldn't get their gas but then
there was so much backlash that they
backtracked afterwards but looking at
austria the czech republic lithuania
and i believe berlin germany as well are
considering mandatory vaccination
otherwise paying
fines or even incarceration it's crazy
in the u.s in 1905 there was a supreme
court ruling that stated you could find
someone in your community if they don't
get vaccinated the fine was five dollars
at the time the equivalent equivalent of
about 150 but that was it that's the
argument used by many of these leftists
to say see we've always had vax mandates
and i'm like
yeah i guess but they were never able my
understanding is they weren't able to
collect the money from them that was the
issue he said he's like i ain't paying
you you can't do anything about it
so i mean sure i guess you can argue you
can find someone but they can still say
no the ultimate issue was that they
could try to compel you to do it but
ultimately could not force the needle
into your arm now the narrative from the
left is like we've always had vaccinates
what about schools and it's like you can
choose not to go to the school you can
choose to move your kids you can get a
medical exemption a religious exemption
now they're outright saying like jim
cramer just have the military mandated
in australia they're look i i think it's
fair to say the australian press and all
these people are lying through their
teeth and at this point i would actually
say that's that's in my opinion
circumstantial evidence to suggest
everything we think about what's going
on in australia is probably a lot worse
than it is they they admit they arrest
three teenagers from escaping from the
quarantine facility okay if that's the
case and claire lehman and whoever else
wants to argue that their international
arrival bungalows where people like hot
babes are sunbathing but then they'll
also tell us you'll be arrested if you
escape i can only assume that it's
substantially worse they're probably
just flogging people in their rooms i'm
kidding by the way i really don't think
they're doing that but if we know
they're lying about everything why would
i even just give them the benefit out in
any capacity so to me this kind of
smacks of an authoritarian government
because i remember when covet first
started
my friend looked at the numbers and said
oh this is coming out of china those
numbers are 10 times what they're
telling us and i was like yes absolutely
so like what you're saying right now
what australia is admitting to is going
to be very much a pr stunt the fact that
they're coming out and saying oh no you
know people aren't you know being forced
to do this or whatever and sending all
these awesome pictures of
ladies in bikinis very strange
advertising for these camps but it's
like
you're hiding something you need to fess
up and they're never going to because
they'll never be held to account which
is a little bit discouraging but at
least the fact that there's a marketing
campaign with women in bikinis in
government quarantine camps is creepier
than the fact that there well there
wasn't it's just the hashtag apparently
yeah
but but the fact that people are
collecting these and making articles and
making stories about this justifying
this bigger power grab by government and
not trying to hold the government
accountable not even talking about
personal responsibility is absolutely
worrying and we're seeing a lot of crazy
stuff happening in europe greece just
made the vaccine mandatory for everyone
over the age of 60. it's pretty much
mandatory in italy already it's pretty
much mandatory in france but it's not
really implemented because people are
not going along with it but in italy
right now you can't board a plane you
can't board a bus you can't board any
kind of public transportation you can't
have any job public or private if you
don't go through uh the government
compliance and you get their approval
and you get a paper saying hey i'm okay
with being able to
you know bow down to government then you
could actually do all of those things
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you